number one that this is in some ways
contrary to American culture that you
know we are free and independent nation
secondly that free markets which is what
they usually are advocating are the best
way to distribute resources within an
economy and they argue that that would
be best for healthcare and thirdly I
think the problem is that they often
represent those entities which indeed
get the benefit from having our present
system namely they are insurance
companies private health insurance
companies the pharmaceutical industry
those are the most common folks who
speak against a single-payer National
Health Insurance Program
let's start with you know what is what
we're calling a single-payer National
Health Insurance Program and let me be
very clear that that's confusing to
people I've had people come up and tell
me you mean I have to be single to
qualify for your health plan no well
what we're talking about is a program
that essentially provides automatic
enrollment for anyone who lives in the
United States that's what real universal
coverage is somebody presents to an
emergency room they don't have health
insurance well let's take the
opportunity and sign you up right there
because you should be automatically
enrolled there's no private health
insurance company in the United States
that would enroll you when you came to
the emergency room the second principle
is that the coverage should be really
comprehensive everything from preventive
care you know through doctor hospital
mental health dental you know to nursing
home care all medically necessary
services the third principle is that
that should be financed by a public
system in essence the way in which we
finance private health insurance today
is using premiums right and premiums are
really relatively unfair the president
of the company pays the same premium as
the secretary yet their incomes are so
widely different public financing means
that it would be scaled according to
income and the fourth principle is that
all of this should be done through a
much more simple administration and
that's what single-payer is so that for
instance the Medicare program which is
our one example of a single-payer
program in the United States has a four
percent overhead three to four percent
whereas private health insurance can be
where's from twenty to thirty percent
and finally all of this should be
delivered essentially through a how to
describe it a private delivery system
it's public financing private delivery
let me say that in addition to that
there should be free choice of doctor
and hospital and really that's what a
single-payer program would offer that
you know right now in private health
insurance you're limited to a network of
doctors and a network of hospitals you
have to pay frequently substantially
more if you want to go outside that
network whereas in single-payer you can
go to any doctor and hospital so you
might ask the question is there any
health insurance program in the united
states that resembles what we're talking
about and i would like to say yes it's
the traditional medicare program it's
essentially a program that is publicly
financed but privately delivered and
that's what we're talking about
well let me start with the white house
conference we were invited largely
because initially someone representing
the single-payer position had not been
invited including representative Conyers
who is the major sponsor of HR 676 the
bill that in the last Congress had 93
co-sponsors in the house it had the most
co-sponsors of any health care bill but
he wasn't invited and then no one was
invited from our organization physicians
for a national health program so we you
know called the White House we had a
people from around the country get
involved we actually even threatened to
do a white coat demonstration outside
the White House and we were finally
invited literally myself the day before
the conference itself so that was how we
got there when we were there we were
able to be full participants and the
essential agenda of the White House
summit on health care I think was three
things one was it was all broadcast on
c-span so the president was saying I'm
being transparent I want you to see
what's happening in health care reform
secondly he invited quite a few Congress
people probably 52 if i count correctly
senators and representatives from the
house but but from both parties so the
second message was I'm going to try to
be bipartisan from the beginning and
then the third message of the summit was
I am NOT going to dictate to Congress
what they come out with I'm handing all
the significant issues over to Congress
so the overall message I think was I'm
doing this different from Hillary
Clinton and the Clintons in general I'm
trying to approach this with
transparency bipartisanship you know and
letting Congress take the initiative now
the problem with that is that I think
the president is going to have to take
leadership here particularly if we're
going to get a significant reform and so
far the notion that you can include the
private health insurance industry and
maintain a multi payer system
essentially i think really flies in the
face of the evidence that it's possible
to do this first you know there isn't
going to be the dollars to grant access
to all those who are uninsured nor to
improve the policies for people who are
underinsured the way single-payer does
that is that it removes a lot of the
administrative costs of private health
insurance but even more importantly the
administrative costs in my office of
having to have an extra person to deal
with all that multiple come you know
insurance companies each of whom have
their own rules in fact hospitals will
have smaller administrative costs we
compared Toronto general with a
similarly sized hospital in the United
States Toronto general has three billers
it is in a single-payer system in Canada
we had over 300 billers in the
comparable sized you know us hospital so
if we convert it to a single-payer
program there would be the funds there
without increasing the overall cost to
the system there would be the funds
there
grant you know universal coverage
automatic enrollment and to improve the
kinds of policies that people have that
they're now getting from private health
insurance companies